[Music]
that's right
baby y
we are all domestic terrorists we are
all domestic terrorist hell yeah that's
right baby that's right there we
are yeah we are coming to you live from
sunny California Los Angeles we are the
Matt Gates holdouts we are the never
cevs never kevs rise up yeah boom damn
you just you just wanted to flex that
Tad didn't you you're like hey hey look
at that look at my tattoo that's
literally what I did Rolex yeah damn you
got you got my house on your wrist dude
your your arm I'm telling you man this
thing wasn't cheap it's peeling though
like crazy it's itchy what do I do
you're kind of a bad boy now have you
noticed that like since you have a a
tattoo you're I noticed that you've
become more of a bad boy I think I feel
it in my soul yeah you know what's next
you going to get a get a bike
motorbike bike start smoking sigs I'll
start with like one of those uh bicycles
with no no no not even that just a
bicycle with an engine yeah yeah you
know the things are dangerous man
they're quiet that's what I'm saying
that's the real bad boy vehicle knock an
old lady out she won't even see you
coming done who's she going to tell
exactly I need to get out of the also
police to announce that I'm wearing a
large
today I mean this
is I mean you did you did this last week
too you know well hold on cuz I haven't
worn a large sweater in a while I had to
pull up the sleeves cuz of my
my Shredder tat yeah cuz you're a bad
boy
but
nice is that I can report I can report
from the side profile I can't see Ethan
like when he's standing next to me I
can't see him he's too skinny that's it
he's too thin a slice of water where did
Ethan go oh no I'm a juicy slice of thin
watermelon yeah um welcome everybody
Welcome Hanan thank you for being here
of course everybody it's Thursday which
means we are going to be making death
threats and bomb threats to physical
locations and real people yeah that's
our
favorite favorite pastime
here I'll say some other I'll say some
other stuff I'll say some other stuff
and then you know it'll be more
controversial uh than it
should are you referring to
something no not at all you don't want
to talk about it no I but what I do want
to talk about is uh Jank yuger your
uncle my uncle is is running for
president then obviously he has your
support right his family I mean we'll
see I got to I got to see what he's up
to you know if he's if he's being if
he's taking it seriously or not what
what's his opinion on um socialized
workplaces well he uh originally did
delay a vote uh internally when ayat was
trying to unionize in his workplace but
it is he has a unionized workshop he
does yeah yeah
yeah good for him he did like a like a
classic this is not like the best
practice in a situation if you own a
business is what Ben and Jerry's did
immediate voluntary recognition uh once
your workers come to you Jen took it
like Jank did one step above that where
he was like oh sure you guys want to
unionize but like let's hold elections
how many employees does he have um I
don't know I have no idea is that a big
project over there
no it's bigger than this but um it's
probably like Teddy fresh levels I would
say or was at the time I don't know I
dude I haven't worked with them
in years like I haven't I were you part
of the unionization efforts no I this is
after I left if I was there I would have
been union busting like crazy i' been
like that's what I was wondering no I I
supported them but from the outside you
know what I mean
scab anyway okay interesting so I
support Ed The unionizing Producers
Ethan I don't know
man yeah no I I was like yeah you guys
shouldn't do that actually have you ever
thought about a PlayStation 5 that's
what you could be pursing with your
union D instead that's Amazon right yeah
yeah it's true though it's true
yeah yeah Union who needs them who needs
them you know um so uh you watched
Banner Brothers congratulations on
becoming a patriotic americ dude I'm so
patriotic problem finally the issue is
there's two different conflicting
factors at play here though because it
made me like so much more patriotic for
America but it also made me like hate
Nazis even more than I previously did
well we got them all so then yeah
exactly except that one dude in Canada
yeah except for that dude in Canada so
like when I so when the waffs
conversation was happening and I sent
you that political article of the guy
being like well actually some of the
waan SS weren't all that bad I was like
losing my mind
um so it backfired on like modern era
liberals who want to defend uh certain
aspects of of uh Nazis and and Nazi
Collaborators because they were like
anti USSR or whatever it just like made
me more angry about that now what but I
moved on to the Pacific now which is not
as good not as good as Tom Han one right
um it's the same people yeah also a real
story not as good nowhere near as good
cuz like I think one of the like one of
the guys that they're following he's
just just like he's just sucking
too much like I feel like he's what do
you mean he's in Australia he's he's
laying pipe in Australia too much fun
yeah like what are you doing and I feel
like that's the difference between like
I mean obviously it wasn't fun right no
the band and the brothers man they were
in trenches they were front line yeah
they were they were getting
annihilated by like German machine gun
fire meanwhile these guys are like
taking a break cuz I think that's the
difference between like being drafted
versus like the draft Enlistment versus
like uh like actively volunteering for
it where you have like more I guess more
amenities they're both drafts no there's
some people in the no people in the it's
the same War I know but some people in
the no but it's the Marine Corps okay
and it's the it's it's the Pacific so
yes there are obviously drafty and and
those who enlisted but then there's also
like voluntary enlistment as well like
people who like but there wasn't on the
on the volunteered I think on the German
front it was more like straight d
they're like nobody wants to come here I
don't know I mean I I might be totally
wrong well anyway Banner Brothers some
of you might not know it's a HBO series
about the a
specific uh group Easy Company it's all
based on like a true story and like uh
specific is based on a true story too so
this company the easy uh easy company
was like so SI this insanely badass
group of Marines that just did like such
insane things they even on General
Patton in it which I thought
awesome cuz like like so there's the
Battle of the Bulge and then uh when
they're when they're uh holding a
position and they're encircled by
Germans and the what was the area
like the the the episodes where it's
like super cold it's like constantly
snowing on them and they're like getting
bombarded yeah um forest and then and
then inevitably General Patton is able
to push uh through that encirclement and
and offer them supplies it's like a big
moment and they very openly State both
in the show and in the historical
documents that they they were like we
never asked for help we never needed
General Patton's help we could have held
the line even without the
resupplies why were they mad about it um
I think because he saw it as a big dub
is he was like liberating uh
paratroopers okay like there was some
there was some internal politics there
well General Patton's also a piece of
like he's a really bad guy
so I think that's why I personally
appreciated them on him but but
uh it's really good it's very intense
and it's
very it's got it all I mean what can you
say it really does I mean World War II
is just you know you don't have to feel
bad about anything you just are can be
full Patriot it depends you don't have
to feel bad about anything well it
depends in Germany not really less so in
Germany we don't talk about we don't
talk about the Pacific we don't deal
with yeah we we don't talk about what
happened no dude that was actually
really interesting to see too like um I
mean it's a historical uh assessment of
the situation so on the one hand like
when they're talking about the Germans
like uh they're like oh they
suck these crows like we're going to
kill them right we're going to kill them
all they're they're barbarians they're
crazy and then when they're talking
about the Japanese on the
Pacific front they're literally just all
the slurs yeah they were just like yeah
these people are just not human they
called them crows which I mean again
they're there there's not really great
yeah there there isn't too much uh like
racialized slurs against like other
white people from white people we got to
bring that back I mean that's it that's
all they had that doesn't hit that hard
it's like sour Crut I mean we that's
what I'm saying uh fellas us whites we
got to figure out new like
anti-white slays I think that's that's
what I'm always that's what we're going
to brainstorm here today actually crack
um don't say that on Twitch um real fast
Teddy fresh drop is out right now Han I
don't know if you look pick through this
one already
but take a look new new isn't it this
just came out today we have the iconic
be ears
puffer jacket it's back in stock now
with
green I love this music thank you we got
the fashion the bear the Build A Bear
hoodie this one's pretty cool it's
modular you can unzip the sleeves you
can even unzip it in half and then
connect it to other pieces damn you
don't have to though either it just
looks really cool it's is a cool feature
what that's sick builda bear oh this is
a really cool dress ela's been wearing
it's really really nice um some camo you
know what I'm saying this is what I'm
wearing dump him well I couldn't say
better
myself I like it thanks bro uh there's
all kinds of fun stuff there oh that b
lava goes hard which one the ballock
lava the
shyy the fuzzy this the fuzzy bear shyy
that's crazy oh yeah Ela posted a
picture where I was like damn you look
like Adventure Time character yeah no I
want that which one do you want wait let
me see the other one ooh I don't
know there's only one size but your head
is small excuse me no it's not my head
is perfectly normal average sized which
one you
want um D I love how the ears pierce
that's I think the green one probably
I'm just trying to see like what I could
mix and match with and I feel like the
green one I could probably wear with
other stuff this one yeah okay there it
is that's the uh what did you call it B
laava the shyy oh that's what it says
here B clava I didn't know what it was
called it's for yeah when I want to when
I want to rob a grocery store style you
know what I mean when I'm doing my my
organized my flash mob at Nordstrom's
yeah I H perer am using a gun to Rob
this
Bank damn where did they get that
out brother uh there's also some
other silly fun goofy teas therapy is
not enough I need to ruin his life am I
right
girl KY has already ruined my life in
certain Oh I thought you were talking
about Ka no just the shirt I don't know
it could be about K I guess um that's it
Teddy fresh.com thank you thank
you uh we got so what basically the main
story here today is the um the McCarthy
stuff there's some really fun alleys
coming in and out of this story I feel
like oh yeah and um but but first we
have some really fun stuff I want to
watch for example RFK Jr who is a uh you
know he's a great guy and we we're all
we wish him uh you know we're all
rooting for we're all rooting for him
that's right yeah here he is uh you know
once again he's such a badass I I don't
know if you guys have seen him shirtless
he can do push-ups and everything yeah I
mean he he's kind of weak for all that
muscle like I've said this a lot I've
kind of duked it out with my trainers on
this cuz like they're like he works out
that's sick like we need a fit president
and I'm like yeah but like you're you're
a this is what you do professionally
like you know he's only putting up
45 Pounders on the incline like
that's his musculature demands way
higher weight no bro he's stacked I
don't know give me a shirt no he looks
he does look stacked but it's just like
odd to me that someone that is that
stacked is not able to put up more
weight especially because like seen lift
why you say that I have seen him lift
yes oh he can't lift a lot um it was odd
because the he was doing an incline
bench press and the weight that he was
putting up was actually not uh I I don't
think it I mean the weight that he was
putting up was was was low for like oh
dude come on bro like for how musular he
is because man this guy dude really
put that out there you went in public
and lifted that one thing I want to
point out here is that like this is an
impressive amount of weight for
uh his size most likely it's just that
when you have been weightlifting for so
many years and you've developed that
level of musculature I I expect I expect
you especially because he definitely is
on something thinked I think he's doing
trt for sure I think so yeah I think
like that's pretty you have to do it at
that point like you if you want to if
you want to maintain this man is like
vaccines I don't think so yeah steroids
I do think so taking the non virgin
vaccine
okay he's taking the vaccine that helps
him right and that's all that
matters this dude is a bad anyway so um
this is the photo that everyone's he's
so cool I mean guys I mean why he looks
great more there to say he looks he
looks phenomenal I'm not going to I I I
would never it's right there in the in
the frame
look I guarantee you got some prime uh
what he looks he looks phenomenal it's
just like there is wait there's oh yeah
there is prime yeah yeah my God he's
sick as dude RFK drinking he sick
as yeah he's like no vaccines but I
love
Prime very healthy for you I don't need
to know what's in it just give it here
so anyway that's RFK he's obviously
jacked which means he's right so another
uh display bro his waist is snatched
okay did you see that he's got
sixpack like I mean I I really respect
that me too no it's m saying why are we
even debating he should be president
thank you and then so he raised a bunch
of money and so to celebrate he said
thank you so much to all who donated for
taking our support base to the next
level I mean hell I'm I'm so thrilled
and this has 50,000 likes so everyone's
feeling it here he
is okay you guys
ready whoa no way dude thank you so much
for all that donated I just that was a
really shitty back flip too I don't know
why he did that like I I don't know why
he cuz he's young he's spry look
at there's something really weird
happening here yeah they I think they
Amplified it with like CGI or something
that's what I think it looks like
there's some weird thing going on here
also the sound effect of him splashing
is like a car detonating it's
like so loud is there something
weird kind of looks like made SP it up
oh my God they they added some splashing
sound effects I don't know why they
would do that so funny I don't know why
he did this to begin with like why did
he do a backflip off of a hill into his
lake or whatever the he's jumping
into cool dude what are you talk
why would you even ask that question I
this shu's my favorite too he looks lost
he looks lost in confused and then they
and they punched into his face like what
thanks all who donated why are you
include this shot look at him man he
doesn't look happy or he looks like what
the I just I don't get it look at
this
huh what the weirdest ad I've
ever
seen you simply don't understand Ethan
that's why he's I mean to be fair he's
got like he has like 16 points dog I
mean maybe he does know something and we
don't you know what I mean like it's not
like out of all of the uh all the other
people that are running like this man
currently is like you know polling
fairly decently for if you ignore the
psycho vaccine and Jewish conspiracies
and stuff like I totally get it but but
you don't understand that is the reason
why he's popular so then that poses an
issue because if you don't have the
vaccine conspiracies and like the the
anti-Semitism that he just like bakes
into it uh then he's just a regular
Democrat you know what I mean I like it
he's like a which which to me uh still
goes back to the the crisis the
Democratic party's facing with Biden
because
like nobody wants him nobody nobody
wants Biden they're
like you know maybe this guy's good no I
don't think I think he's probably take
from what I understand he's RFK is most
likely taking more votes away from
Donald Trump absolutely yeah he's he's a
spoiler not for Brandon but for Trump
which is so awesome and he's aware of
that so I think that's a dub at least
for our boy you know what I mean you
know and if a few Jews have to dieet to
get him in office then so be it here's
his IND the favor abilities
with uh Republicans and Democrats yeah
it's it's interesting oh that's so sick
dude that's awesome he's I if he runs
third party it's like a GG
Trump I mean I think it's it's GG Trump
in general unless dude I've said this
already I think if it wasn't Biden
currently president but the but the
administration was doing like a lot of
the things that it's doing currently
um like you could see the Democrats win
by like Ronald Reagan levels like
unheard of uh uh victories it's
optimistic no I'm but it's Biden and
he's very old wait are you calling a 49
State Landslide no maybe 50 maybe I'm
not
pimp are you sure dude I'm not pimp tool
but what I'm what I'm simply stating is
that
um some of the stuff that the Biden Camp
has done thus far has been pretty decent
like surprisingly shockingly more
Progressive more Pro labor than I would
expect more poor labor than definitely
like the the Obama Administration by a
wide margin I I definitely I will admit
um having said that however uh because
it's associated with like a decrepit
carcass
people immediately say his age is a
major consideration for them a cause for
concern I'm gay yeah so Trump I mean
Trump is beating Biden right now in the
polls he's beating Biden in the polls
currently um here is RFK on Theo Von why
why can't why can't we get
him why I well that that might be part
of the reason I well that that part of
that's part the reason the other reason
is because you have ashkanazi Jew DNA oh
he you have you have ashkanazi Jews
in your quarters that have avoided Co
Zach's the one Zach's Ground Zero man
yeah come on Bobby come on the show come
give me Aug come on give me a hug I
won't bite I promise yeah I don't think
we've asked though so what we haven't
reached out we've reached out oh we did
yeah never mind yeah Zach reached out so
he was like no oh that was he saw he saw
his last
name oh Jesus you need you need to get
love to reach out to him
let's try that as a social experiment
right now anyway here's he's talking
about Theo Von about him running as
third party and then the other thing is
that I take more votes from president
Trump than I do from President Biden
right so why would that help them yeah
it's not helping them yeah yeah but and
then the other Republicans got real mad
at this then right so here it is by Jack
uh prolapse thing awful person
so he they're calling the
the warhorn on RFK now they're turning
on him nothing funnier to me than like
this guy being a q andon guy and he was
literally like a naval intelligence guy
it's like what do you think Naval
intelligence is like you think that's
not the Deep State you idiots
deep yes never forget Jack poo uh spent
his entire wedding tweeting at me like
his entire wedding yeah he live streamed
his wedding and I was making fun of him
and he like they they're such culture
Warriors he ordered
like uh he ordered Papa Johns I think if
I'm not mistaken for his that was his
catering for his wedding and he spent
the entire wedding tweeting at me
complaining that turns me on there it is
he did he did Papa John yeah these guys
CU of the n-word they're so they're so
committed to like virtue signaling and
supporting like this man catered Papa
John's to his wedding I mean that this
is not the way that you want to
consummate that that ceremony no he
loved it dude he was like Papa
I want that sweet buttery garlic breath
you're dipping into that on your
wedding night man I know who didn't
get laid that
night
mhm yeah so anyway there's that so we
love RFK
now we're fan that's what we're taking
out of that conv we're fans our goat
also just something about Ronda santis
real fast the kids on Tik Tok have
realized something's fishy about this
man something is very off wait really oh
yes take a look dude I never see take to
oh dude dude dude oh that's awesome you
what are
those yo they're first of all why do
they he looks like he's wearing clown
shoes first of all like the way that
they curl up yeah there's something I
think they're
right no he is wearing diagram makes it
I don't know if you guys know this but
little Ronda is little like Trump is
like 63 little Rhonda is like 510 I
think I think he's 5
no hold on cuz that's part of this 510
with the heels no hold on guys there
there's evidence here now Nikki Haley
says she's 5'8 okay here is Ronnie show
the makeup one no here's Ron standing
next to her on stage she's 58 why
wouldn't he have the heels on there he
does look at his crazy ass weird
balenciagas you know the Balenciaga like
clown shoes yeah that's what is he
wearing that what's he why do they look
like he looks like a he looks like a cow
hoof that hasn't been cut in a year I
watch hoof cleaning videos oh me too
they're so SI you seen that they're
so satisfying they have to bring out
like the uh the pliers and I love
that what a weirdo so she's
5'8 I love they both got 4 in heels
on so what's happening damn these people
are doing like in-depth analysis on be 5
is what I'm saying Tik tok's like I
don't give a about his policies
like let's get into the let's get into
what really matters how tall is this
oh man all not
Oliver
5 so AB you agree right I mean you know
about this not I'm not saying I just
know that you know about it I I wore a
converse with the lift and now I'm an
expert no the converse are on the
outside it's not on the inside no no but
I you know all about this right like the
third time accusing me of this no it's
not Hassan Hassan has the same uh oh the
platform I have those I you made fun of
me before for those too remember those
are big like those souls are like this
big hold on no you have you have got
like the sneaky heels don't you no no I
have I have a dock and a pair of
Converse those are the only two I have
wait you have platform Commerce I didn't
even know platform Commerce that's what
I'm saying they're they're sneaky hold
on let me pull them up pull them up
these are just s Dam you just ruthless
right now dude I don't know why a big
game for a guy who's who's not even 510
me yeah that's not even true like you
can at least if you're can make fun of
my height at least tell the truth you
say I'm 510 and 3 these right yeah but
then it's like a high heel inside no
inside it's it feels the same just the
outside MH and I saw these on Howe
mandale and I'm like those look kind of
sick yo but you're you're not short so I
don't know why you you know what I mean
like but I yeah I mean hanan's not short
it's it's the style of it right it's the
style like the Crocs you're wearing now
I like it yeah they're not the high heel
Crocs that you have to be fair I did buy
those docks I did buy those docks when I
uh didn't have a lot of money and I
bought them online thinking that they
were going to be cuz they were the only
ones with the zippers on the side and I
hate tying my I have no problem with
these it's Stolen Valor D it's very no
but look it's very honest about it what
they're doing right it's not camouflaged
you know I think it's sick though I do
like the look of it like having like
those big Souls I like those I even
bought the I even have those ones too
the the short ones with the big Souls as
well those are a little funky the third
one like bowling shoes with a
they're they're cool anyway I got no
problem with those ones I got no problem
with anything yeah you know I think it's
it's mischievous and deceptive if you're
guys the the filter broke Ethan's real
size is leaked again let me go grab your
shoes Ethan hold
on you can just stand for the rest of
the episode feeling pretty tall now
yeah same height as me while
you're
standing stand up then no that's one
small step for man I'm not I'm not
continuing till you fix
it oh my God he's huge oh my God I'm not
continuing until you fix it
bro small man
man small man what the that yo you
better fix that Ian if you don't
want me to call on you and include your
ass in the show you better not be shrink
wrapping me like that dude this is not
Honey I Shrunk the Kids this is
left over there you go there you
go perect cuz I can get I can play this
game too Ian what you going to do you
going to shrink him he I'm telling you I
know how to torture him he knows I
know you know
um oh here's Howe yeah he's a fashion
icon though he really is he's got crazy
fit game damn dude yeah and he's like
how old is he like 70 he's harder at
that age to just like looks stylish you
know what I mean dude Howie is so
healthy he looks oh he's
67 he looks so good he's got
fashion he's got it all I mean I I I
look up to Howie I really do is Seaman
bad for PL
right right I don't know anything about
him I just know the anal prolapse thing
he's a good guy he's a really good guy
okay I only know that and I can't even
tell every being sarcastic right no I no
he's a big time friend of the show I'm
not so uh we got some new sound bites
from Trump that are really good let's
just let's hear these out thank you to
Trump um let's see what we got here this
week they've oh he's so bad he's got so
many good ones president what they've
done is they've gone after a opponents
so that if you become president or some
other job but if you become president
and you don't like somebody or if
somebody's beating you by 10 15 or 20
points like we're doing with crooked Joe
Biden it's coming let's indict the
what he did you can he say
that is he allowed to say that he can do
whatever he wants man what they've done
is they let's Indi the IND
the let's indict the
he's so so good it's so
good
[Music]
let's indict the
IND there was one about him
talking about like whether he would
rather be killed by sharks or
electrocution did you guys see that one
you know what I had that let me grab
that I had it last week and we just
didn't get to it but let me uh that one
was fire too here he is taunting Nancy
Pelosi's husband who was viciously uh
beaten by
a David let's see what I'm sure he has
thoughts and prayers for for
him and we'll stand up to crazy Nancy
Pelosi who ruined San
Francisco
oh how's your husband doing by the way
anybody know dude that's crazy
crazy that's a mic drop wait that's
actually that's like you know that's
Mafia I'll be honest I'd be honest
if he was I would if I if he was really
on it right now he would have tied it up
and been like he's probably doing well
he's doing great in stocks and then that
would have been like that would have
been repeated uh on his on his uh
campaign uh Dub's
announcement this is still pretty good
this is pretty Next Level man he's just
basically like I'm so glad that dude got
his ass beat by conspiracy who got
almost killed slammed in the head by by
a trump supporter that's the part we're
forgetting he San
Francisco Bo
how's your husband doing by the way
anybody
know let's kill him kill him I mean and
she's against building a wall kill him
with the
hammer shut up she's against building a
wall to what keep David de peee out like
what the do you mean homie what are
you talking about he was a white guy who
was your fan what are you
saying yeah
land but it's it doesn't do any good
because Nome and any
Democrat Governor they won't allow us to
have water you know you have massive
amounts of water coming down from up
North that's so true new won't let us
have water I can understand about the
water but I don't understand why would
they do that why are these patches so
magnificently green and it's a very
small talking about water or Border
Water he always goes on about water like
it's water yeah water not water rice he
no he just wants more pressure in the
shower and the toilet oh oh oh oh oh oh
that's okay
can't go down in one flush yeah he's a
he's a single issue voter
man's he he hyper fixates on one thing
and then he makes the entire campaign
the shower thing is really easy to fix
just go block Market pretty much yeah
but here's the thing underground I don't
know if you know this but gold is not it
doesn't it's not like nonporous like um
porcelain is so when you in a gold
toilet get stuck it doesn't stay gold
for long let me tell you that you think
that's what you think that's his problem
that all of his Poopers are gold well
cuz his toilets are gold get stuck in
the ball I think you're I think you're a
liberal and you're lying oh you know my
my president takes the best shits
cleanest shits people perfect log yeah
he doesn't even have to wipe
normally they would get only under
under normal circumstances they would be
flushed immediately but Communists uh
communist Chinese backed Governor Gavin
Newsome has ruined that for Trump yeah
that's what it is as you know California
is well known for not having water
problems so let's just let it flow small
areas but most of the Farmland they
don't let St touch they won't let us
touch it if I could do it it would be
billions of billions if they if they
changed this and we worked on it and
I'll explain that nobody's following it
would be billions and billions of extra
dollars coming into the state and coming
into our country and we have the water
and I said what about the desalinization
PL people don't like him because you
know I said what about a nice big
beautiful D they're building them all
over it just takes like 10 years to do
it big beautiful plant big beautiful
salty plant and we'll package the salt
we'll send it all over the world
genius it does decimate the local
ecosystem so you need to be careful
about that but who cares we got to have
water
right um let's see Nancy
I sent you the uh the one you were
asking about with the sharks okay here
we
go ah and I'm on top of a
battery okay start flooding in people on
liberal on liberal media ew yuck uh made
this seem like Trump was just like not
on it you know he was just like slurring
his speech and going crazy this is
Clarity baby okay let me tell you
something what you're about to hear from
Trump is probably going to make you want
to vote for him cuz he's got some great
ideas this man is a modern day
philosopher uh and this is simply a
logical conundrum let's hear let's hear
him out all right but if I'm sitting
down and that boat's going down and I'm
on top of a battery uhhuh under waterer
starts flooding in I'm getting concerned
but then I look 10 yards to my left and
there's a shark over there so I have a
choice of electrocution or shark you
know what I'm going to take
electrocution I will take electrocution
every single time do we agree what the
I will take electrocution do you
not agree what is the scenario he's
painting he's on a batter be eaten by a
shark or electrocuted to death shows
Wrong by the way cuz electrocution is
like you're going to die correct sharks
they they probably won't attack you no
the sharks are going to attack you
they're going to sharks will attack you
he's right he's so right about this oh
he's right yep yeah huh but why is he on
a battery he's on a boat that's sinking
he said he's on a battery and he's
sitting on top of a battery down and
that boat's going down and I'm on top of
a battery top of battery of a boat yes
he has this like hangup about electric
boats he thinks uh I I saw another thing
of him from a different speech I think a
week ago where he was complaining about
how it makes no sense to have an
electric boat because you're in the
water and electricity and water don't go
together there's a lot of electric uh we
on I think he made a good point there
I'm sending I'm sending a very important
article perhaps the most important
article I've ever sent to the Discord
please take a look at it I'm on a
battery and the boat is going down it's
uh it's from uh the New York Magazine
intellig where'd you send it I uh just
put it in here um oh wait wait wait wait
wait oh you got it okay cool so the
so wait no not that one oh
no this is the the separate article
there's always Donald Trump hates sharks
yeah really and he has hated sharks for
a very long time according to store me
Daniels in in an older interview uh uh
she revealed that Donald Trump hates
sharks and then of course back in the
day they uh back in 2018 they key
searched shark on Donald Trump's Twitter
to find out that my man has been hating
sharks for a minute which I agree I
agree with him on it okay this one is so
good sorry folks I'm just not a fan of
sharks and don't worry they will be
around long after we are gone which I
don't know what that means it's ominous
I mean that's that may that's probably
not true at the at the rate we're going
sharks are these two tweets are two
minutes apart too he are last on my list
other than perhaps the losers and haters
of the
world yeah he's like Hillary Clinton and
sharks I hate him Puerto r wow and yet
he still preferred to be eaten by them
than on a battery on a no no he
preferred to be electrocuted he did yeah
cuz he hates like he under well let me
rephrase that he understandably has a
fear of
sharks uh and being eaten by sharks
right which I
respect sure I mean they are scary
looking I wonder what he thinks a shark
tank or like anything shark I don't
think he likes anything shark related he
is talking about electric motor boat you
know I've never thought of that actually
but I think I gave him an I said what
happens if the boat has an accident
starts sinking do you get electrocuted
if the boat wait till he finds out about
nuclear powered boat actually IDE going
to really blow his mind now can
you imagine the boat goes down and
you're sitting on top of a battery I
don't I don't feel good about that right
he's like no power the ships what what's
going on
folks hirosima very bad that's what they
want these Cruisers these big beautiful
Cruisers they're like cities on there's
like an island that moves powered by
nukes to answer this question you would
not be electrocuted because the ocean is
enormous I
think well I think at that point if your
boat is sinking your boat is
sinking but I don't think that's even
how batteries work just
discharge um the water I don't think I
I'm not a scientist I don't know I don't
know how uh electric batteries work in
the ocean I'm pretty sure uh salt water
does uh legitimately harm electric
batteries inside of EVS way worse than
like it would other kinds of batteries
and I do think that uh that fire can am
I crazy about this we need to fact check
this find I like I I think that it's
like get another one of those like Trump
moments where like he's not entirely
incorrect well let's find out cuz maybe
maybe he's on to something you know well
it's all kind of moot I mean boats have
had batteries on them for a long time oh
yeah yeah it's not not massive ones like
this I think they have uh
no not freaking massive uh pesas siiz
batteries yeah we need to find
out what I'm I'm confused what electric
boat goes down will you be electrocuted
okay electric boat sink elect so there
there is a truth to electric vehicle
fires caused by saltwater flooding this
is a very real problem but they're meant
they're built to be on
saltwater e are not but the the issue is
like cargo ship uh containers that
actually also are are are for example
shipping electric vehicles um they do
end up sometimes going down and uh
causing massive uh ecological disasters
like the the cargo ships are sinking
there was yeah there was a Porsche yeah
there was a cargo ship a couple years
back like right around the time when I
got my car and when you got your car
there was a Porsche Volkswagen cargo
ship that was carrying a bunch of
electric vehicles like a bunch of Tans
uhhuh uh went down there was a there was
a car battery fire and you can't put
those out with normal
means um so the ship just went down in
its entirety and I don't know if it was
because of saltwater contamination or if
it was a separate reason but I do
remember it being u a much larger issue
than like regular fires well we need to
get to the bottom of this this is
important and it's urgent okay
okay um moving on thank you while that
while everybody's working feverishly to
backck
that yeah Don Jun has been out there uh
doing his thing let's see what Don boys
up too okay I'm seeing uh features like
watertight electrical enclosures and
ground fall protection devices are built
in electric boats to guard against
electric shock that's what I would think
I think that they would if they're going
to put they would probably think about
that yeah they have redundancies for
sure he's ridiculous about that he's
just using like he's using like
something I mean he's doing the classic
thing where it's like it's Common Sense
think about it you know but but he's
just doing stick right he's not trying
to like end the the boat industry the
electric boat industry anyway here he is
uh Lulu Lemon doesn't have a lot of
bread all right I'm sorry what thank you
uh next clip wait wa what did he say
Lululemon doesn't have a lot of bread we
got to cut that Z Lululemon lulon
doesn't have a lot of bread I believe he
said uh Lululemon
doesn't uh Lululemon doesn't have a lot
of bread
well said why are people clapping for
that a lot of bread in a Lululemon
there's not a lot of Lulu Lemon oh say
because people robbed the Lululemon um
he's like oh they're robbing it to what
you think those are
robbing Lululemon to like wear yoga
pants like what the is wrong with
you no they're robbing it to sell it
idiot and then with money you can buy
bread yeah then which they are buying
they're buying bread yeah you know you
know what you pay with bread loaves okay
so you know that's why people rob it
this is not like uh I'm not saying it's
awesome to do crime before anybody
Clips me out of context and goes
there goes this on again promoting crime
there's a reason why rioting H rioting
and looting doesn't happen in a in a in
a vacuum yeah exactly there's causes and
people don't want to be riers and
looters they don't wake up or they're
not born like I'm going to be a rider
and looter it's cause yeah it's a stick
job it's got good uh security yeah you
don't understand organized retail theft
it's out of control dude they're
they're putting on the teddy fresh shyy
and going into Walgreens the with the
express purpose of shutting them down
that's why they're doing it they hate it
you definitely don't go loot a store
unless you're very desperate yes it's
not a great you know and there's a lot
more people that are very desperate now
than ever before clearly based on the uh
frequency let's not make anything else
out of that though let's not even
consider uh how to fix that in a more
permanent way and let's just keep doing
exactly what we've been doing which is
uh Draconian deterrence measures and and
mass incarceration and enslavement of of
specific subss of the American
population under funding uh social
programs it's been great so far I think
Lululemon needs to start selling bread
yeah bread com uh Lululemon doesn't have
a lot of
bread I'm looking at this I mean the
irony of this F oh no one cl for him
doesn't nobody even know what he was
trying to say was like pure nonsense you
guys played the clapping sound yeah yeah
yeah oh my God I thought I was I shocked
I was like why are people clapping for
that nobody understood what he said cuz
we have to listen to like five
times crickets everyone's like huh yeah
um the irony coming from this
guy who grew up in Trump Tower talking
about how Lululemon doesn't have
bread head on a on a pike brother you
don't understand dude he's a
conservative though so he's a real
rugged he's a real rugged guy he's a
real run-of-the-mill working class guy
okay yeah cuz I'm looking at the store
I'm like there's not a lot of bread in a
Lululemon there's not a lot of bread in
the Gucci store and yet everyone seems
like unless you're eating Gucci loafers
which you're probably
not dude he's doing this Dad thing with
his teeth I think that's Coke teeth for
him I don't think he's trying to be like
his dad I think he's just like on so
much CRA definitely yeah the crack
that's the proletarian Coke he might
eating Gucci loers which you're probably
not but this is the incen you remember I
remember most oh God are so bad his TI F
dude honestly I'm woke now I'm so woke I
think comedy should be illegal this kind
of Comedy should be illegal okay that
should be illegal
not and yes it did trigger me but not
for the reasons that you think it
triggered me for okay you can't do that
he's a good at post I mean he does he
make you want to do Coke I mean the coke
lobb is probably loving this he's really
a good so lame he's out there he's got
energy he looks dumb but he's confident
I mean that's what does sh dude I feel
like if I if
I excuse me fact check it's a whole
bread aisle Don
Jr Lululemon does have a lot of cake
though you know what I'm saying they got
a whole lot of ass in there mhm they got
the whole damn B
so that comes from the Trump family
Crowder is uh making a break into the
New Vertical the much sought after
manosphere in fact he's brought on uh
the two great ERS of our time fresh and
fit coconuts and
Barbados to discuss the finer points of
dating of course coming from a guy who
has never had a serious relationship in
high school college orever it it's it's
so stupid dude it's so it's like
uh it's like asking a caveman
about astrophysics you know what I mean
it's like you are the least qualified
person to talk about this and and I mean
coconuts and Barbados I don't even think
you can consent to be in a
relationship like I can't get the I
can't get the behind the Dome view on
this but it does seem like he got hair
plugs no yeah he did he did ask him
about that like he could he's more
knowledgeable on that issue I think I
think he's upfront about it I think no
but I'm saying like that is an area of
of expertise for at least right not like
how to have sex with women I mean if
anybody sleeps with coconuts they should
probably
be that's non-consensual sex act as far
as I'm concerned cuz he doesn't have the
mental
capacity to consent oh you took it in a
different direction never mind he can't
consent and it's up that he I saw
where he was going yeah I know you were
the only one I have to spell it
out all right here's here's the Geniuses
on crowder I think you need to be able
to identify women that are permitt
promiscuous and a way to do that is by
Sleeping with them and I'll say
this we got to ID the Coconut's
taking it all in yeah that's why that's
why they're doing it except you know I I
don't believe
it the reason why it's sleeping with
them versus just courting them and
dating them is because that's a woman's
main commodity like once you sleep with
her you've pretty much conquered that
woman not to sound crazy but you're
you're you're able to identify the gam
even Crowder was like a little sound a
little nuts much conquered that woman
that to sound crazy but you're you're
you're able to identify the game little
bit who wait go back what the he
went mustache I got that's woman's main
commodity like once you sleep with her
you've pretty much conquered that woman
that's to sound crazy but you're you're
you're able to identify a little bit oh
my God bro
bro H the mustache is supposed to be
like a Tom celic effect right it made
him look way gayer dude went in the
other direction sometimes the mustache
can go Village uh the Village People
what they no this is like uh what is it
to Finland yeah my man is my man's
looking like a like a like a t Finland
uh guy that went through like a like a
AI filter to make him look more
pudgy but you know I got to tip the hat
to Crowder a little bit this is the guy
who literally was on camera abusing his
wife and he goes yeah that's a little
crazy to Fresh yeah he's dialing he's
dialing a little bit and I was on camera
abusing my wife he's he's yeah he's
grown he's grown he's learned from his
mistakes by the games yeah well no I but
then it could also become you know this
is where we would disagree but I think
it becomes a vicious cycle because then
not wanting women to have a high body
count and you have a body count of 50 R
it makes it that's kind of what femin
like he's trying they they have to be
nice to each other cuz they don't want
to piss off the fan base this man said
to find out if women are we have
to sleep with them and Crowder's like
well you know it doesn't make that much
sense you know it's like if you sleep
with them then they're sleeping with
people yeah in any San world this guy
who like positions himself as like a
conservative traditional Christian
values guy should want nothing to do
with freshman fit right right well you
have to remember something Stephen
Crowder is on the record like being
anti- sex right he he has written
articles
about uh about how oh my God that's
crazy I'm sorry what happened Alfredo is
so cute a he just he just
plopped over and just
went a sleepy time for him sorry I just
my ADHD got out of control there for a
second it's understandable can't stop
looking at him now and his little pink
belly uh here is Crowder well he's
waiting till the wedding night to get to
get laid Yeah Sten Crow is written
articles about abstinence uh and how
it's actually cool and good and sick and
let's talk to fresh and fit today who
say women to find out if they're
promiscuous yeah why why why not having
sex might be good for you by Steven
Crowder is this about waiting for
marriage or just being like abstaining
yeah abstinence abstinence only sex said
abstinence only before marriage but he's
saying once you're married you you're
good yeah I don't know how that tracks
with like uh you know once you're
married you're good but like what about
what about around what about
sleeping around when you are married I
don't know what about showing your
to all your homies no that's just that's
fine that's just Brotherly Love Bo
yeah um all right thank you to Crowder
uh most predicated on they go men are
doing this so we should the truth it's
not really it's not good for anyone but
I understand what you're you're trying
to say this is the the reality of the
world we live in hopefully there's a
hopefully there is split the difference
you were in law enforcement right you
were in law enement you ever get on how
to spot a fake ID may not have been part
of what you're doing right but no yeah
like fraulin documents yeah yeah so
anybody that's trained on how to spot a
fake ID studies the original you don't
study The Fakes because that can change
you study the original so that you can
understand and see when something is off
so I would disagree with you
wholeheartedly on this bro this is you
go this isn't a science experiment it's
a it's just dating you know what
I mean just go find someone that you're
compatible with and have fun you know
you don't have to know how many people
they like you just don't you
don't have to know
that I love that the damn near entirety
of the you know the male manosphere
space is simply just like
repackaging being an insecure loser as
though it's actually a virtue and not a
vice true like if you look at any of the
commentary from the
manosphere it's almost always just like
yeah women are they they're sleeping
around they might be having sex with
people that are like way better at sex
than you and you're probably bad at sex
but like guess what you know that's
that's not on you you shouldn't you know
that that personal emotional hang-up
that you have is actually their problem
somehow you know what I mean it's just
it's ridiculous but of course there are
plenty of insecure men out there so they
want to be hug booxed they want to feel
good about themselves and uh and and
they don't want to do it in a productive
manner they don't want to do therapy so
they just listen to these guys who lean
into their biases and um they go along
with it instead of reexamining what is
the issue that makes them feel this way
well it's kind of the problem with all
extremist groups since the internet came
out you have a group of people who in
before the internet they were shunned
and people were like you need to change
the world doesn't need to change you're
weird now they all find each
other online and they go no we're normal
there's a lot of us and we don't need to
change and this is what's happening and
the more isolated we become the more
alienated we become from our labor but
the more isolated we become in a hyper
atomized soci no in a hyper
atomize put put your aquafer on okay I
did um but yeah the more isolated we
become uh in our increasingly atomized
Society the more people want uh because
we are social animals we want a
collective identity right and in America
you can't do that on on the basis of
class you can't do that in your
workplaces so you end up doing it over
Commodities that you consume and other
cultural signifiers that say you're a
right-winger you know what I mean or or
personal emotional and moral Hang-Ups
that you might have so that is what's
going on with the manosphere is there's
there there are always going to be
people that feed on that vulnerability
that you that you experience that you
that you have yeah oh the manosphere I
love their song The manosphere yeah m a
n o and this is actually what you're
talking about Hanan this is a bunch of
you know
workingclass com together being boys you
know Sal to the Earth all American you
know electricians Cowboys cops gay
bikers you know what else he solidarity
Native Americans you know it's they're
salt of the earth you know what else is
salty what what it's not good joke I'm
not going to say I know yeah okay I'm
not going to say it I I have no idea
what your R say so let's just move on I
guess it's not that funny it's for the
best yeah yeah somehow Dan can read my
mind I just we worked together too long
I get it oh that's funny it
wasn't funny it wasn't that it wasn't
offensive it just wasn't funny right not
that funny yeah yeah
yeah all right thank you moving on
McCarthy uh McCarthy now before we get
into McCarthy's
downfall he was removed from
speaker by Matt Gates and all his free
Kazo uh never KS would you excuse me um
Brave bold I'm a never Kev but they
voted for him they were a onepe the
entire Democratic Party voter formed
yeah that's
right no no no he voted in favor of him
being speaker at one point he was he was
a for one moment a
Kev I guess that is true he can't
technically you're not wrong about not a
never he can't claim that you know
that's Stolen Valor but you know it's
compromise sometimes you got to do
compromise like the Democratic party
what did the Democratic party do this
past week just like everyone always asks
reach across the aisle they found
bipartisanship in removing Kevin
McCarthy from the speakership position
absolutely so to to them I applaud that
I am I am also a Centrist Democrat a
Centrist liberal and also a never Kev
and and I think that it was wonderful
and good that the Democratic party held
hands with
Republicans got this done unity love
respect and uh in the interest of
productivity as well
yeah so before we get into it there's
this really funny little side street
about this guy Jamal Bowman yes he's a
Democrat Who who okay so he ran on a
more Progressive platform than he
actually is in my opinion in Bronx and
he is
um he he used to be a former principal
um don't care about any of that I mean
he's he's a he's an interesting guy he's
also actually yaked he is so jacked he
Hees like three plates on the B
son I don't care about any of that this
is what I care
about the man pulled the fire alarm yes
he did during uh Congress while they
were it was not during the vote but
before when they were leading up to the
vote he was trying to rush over there to
votee for the clean resolution he pulled
the fire alarm and he pulled the fire
alarm and I will defend him now hold on
cuz there there's a whole lot like
what's going on here so initially people
thought that he did it to Del lay a vote
uh to stop Gap the bill during a time
when Democrats were scrambling to read
the bill okay so so he people thought it
was a delay tactic yeah okay however
Bowman explains uh something quite
different here he is
oh he put out a statement here this is
official well part of before the
statement uh let's just say that the
Republican media ecosystem took this as
Jamal Bowman is a terrorist I've got all
this he is the January sixer uh he was
trying to delay uh you know uh
Congressional like the Congressional
process in the same way that January
6ers did you want to read this Trump uh
sure this Trump tweet will Congress
Jamal Bowman be prosecuted and
imprisoned for very dangerously pulling
and setting off the main fire alarm
system in order to stop a Congressional
vote that was going on in DC his
egregious Act is covered on tape a
horrible display of nerve and
criminality criminality it was a very
dangerous obstruction of an official
proceeding the same as used against our
j6 prisoners
his act may have been worse he must
suffer their same fate when will his
trial begin execute him that's what I
say here's Crowder he se he dedicated a
whole segment to this it was written by
a four-year-old just to be
[Laughter]
clear I I just love Yeah he was going he
was trying to open the door so he pulled
this alarm and it was confusing uh of
course that that that that obviously
that dog won't hunt it's really
undeniable at this point we've done it
in the past but we need to revisit this
for a second I want to explain something
here one you ever heard that that dog
won't hunt a prim song um I just want to
point something here okay that door is
normally open okay that is a door that
is normally open they put those
impromptu signs on top of it that was
like already confusing hold on before
you try to cut before you try to acquit
him this is what the door looked like
when he pulled it exactly so why the
did he pull the fire
I think he mistakenly while he was
rushing over to the other uh rushing
over to the other building which was
across the lawn on the other side what
the he literally read the sign and
because it says push until alarm sounds
for 3 seconds door will unlock in 30
seconds so he probably tried to push it
it didn't unlock so he thought like okay
if I pull the fire alarm like the door
will unlock that's crazy though which is
which is really dumb like make no
mistake look at this this but that door
is normally open Ethan
okay well it wasn't today that's what
I'm saying though it's like what does
what the sign is confusing I'll give
youus I don't know how I I don't think I
ever would have arrived at the
conclusion that I need to pull the fire
alarm to open the
door alarm sounds 5 seconds I
agree Push the door what kind of
emergency exit plan is that just wait
here for 30 seconds and it will probably
open bro it's a very strange sign I
don't know what that means what kind
that that's not an emergency and also
it's it's additionally strange
considering that that door is not
considered an emergency exit only and
it's just perfectly open on other uh in
in other times throughout the day and
also other times throughout the week so
he's like that's a door I take every
time I go you know and and I don't know
why the it's not opening right now
but it probably isn't that big of a deal
here let me try to open it apparently oh
go ahead the other side of this is like
they're trying to say he was trying to
delay the vote right trying to delay the
vote mhm
dog the Democratic party was already on
board with voting for The Clean
resolution and he literally went and
voted for it it's not like he won them
any time like the truth is that it did
he didn't gain anything from it it was
probably just a really bizarre up
uh and it's just the whole story is very
funny apparently Crowder has a really um
spectacular racist rant about it foxen
uh there was a a Fox and Friends lady
who literally said they think they're a
of the law because I have that because
of yeah okay so here let's listen to
Steven Crowder and that other lady who's
insane this is time for uh this week's
installment of Jamal Bowman what a piece
of chill man got a graphic
dude wait why is Jamal Bowman a piece of
this part two dude it's not even a
funny title you're just
angry part two now he did defend himself
I don't know if you guys saw he said I
want to be very clear this was not me in
any way trying was him that was not me
oh trying to delay the vote
okay now here's the thing that right
away seems like protesting too much but
then he goes on to say it was the exact
opposite hold on a second so it was the
opposite so you were trying to really
really vote again the facts of the
situation
clearly that it was a mistake and that
he wasn't trying to uh like like what
what is the what's their opinion on this
like what they don't why would he why
would he try to delay the vote and not
vote for the thing that he voted
for immediately after they don't need to
analyze it any further you know what I
mean that this is enough for for the
audience but I mean listen it's
embarrassing and he definitely looks
like a dumbass so to me that's
enough he thought that was a lever yeah
I was trying urgently to get to a vote
which I ultimately did all right come on
now W well did he or didn't he now to be
fit his defense there were early reports
that he did indeed smell
smoke I think that I think that there
was a reason that they did it tool man
all right never mind oh jeez
Tim oh but hunter smoking crack that's
epic all right he does smoke crack it's
an epic slam oh makes sense fired
admonish yourself admonish yourself Tim
come on that one was that one was timing
Reliance smoking crap that was a good
joke and he was slow to admonish
himself all three of them Yo he's got
like three sound guys Zach what's going
on here nothing funnier than thinking
about how all three of those dudes may
or may not have seen Steven Crowder's
dick or have like had Steven Crowder's
on their should probably multiple
times do they do sound bites it's kind
of something like that I mean he's
operating tricaster or whatever
clowns bro that's a high budget Studio
though damn yeah it's a nice board they
got they got a nice place nice place
they even got that on air sign that's
fancy we don't have one of those uh we
do but you have to manually plug it in
so doing we don't have the Manpower yeah
I'm not doing just lazy I'm just saying
I could I could challenge those guys
three on one yeah of course three on one
obviously battle this operation is
bloated he's very white although he
doesn't pay them he bar he barely pays
them as I understand it so yeah that's
easy to get lots of Labor and exploit it
baby all type type one
fibers I just I don't know why do not me
any way trying to delay the vote it was
the exact opposite of that I was trying
really really hard sir sir no not the
ACC are you stealing from this Walgreens
no I stealing from this Walgreens it
looks like you have
$994,000 merchandise sir
994 like why so specific he's I think
he's just I mean he's saying like Jamal
Bowman is black so he's stealing from
Walgreens right that's what he's trying
to say yeah which of course also
$994,000 you know what that's literally
one packet of baby food actually one tub
of baby food up dude mhm pay for
oh this no this is the exact it's the
opposite of stealing I was going to take
it out so that I could pay for it out
there come back here and buy it again
why how do you buy your
Pharmaceuticals no shot they think this
is fun there's no
shot right there's two of them man
they're both laughing where do I get
these
guys I need you you you want a pair of
twins to chuckle at everything gallery I
take three of them triplets call
them peut and
gallery that makes no sense are you a
racist all right just steal the
it's the dumbest argument I've ever
heard I pulled a fire alarm because I
didn't know how to work a door that has
a sign on it that yeah he's an idiot
that's the point okay whatever dumb
asses uh let's watch this um the fox one
you were mentioning
here oh wait no this
is okay here Jamal Bowman fire alarm
stunt was criminal and and
unethical so why isn't he being chared
wanted to go away that's right bury the
story they're burying the story man it's
crazy and and they're burying the story
by collaborating with Matt gates to
unseat Kevin McCarthy so that people
talk about that instead of Jamal
Bowman's criminal actions go away he
should be executed no thank you very
much uh we know you've got to go
otherwise somebody's going to pull the
fire actually just one last thing we
have 20 seconds uh what are you going to
do Nicole motakis wants uh Bowman
Congressman Bowman out are you going to
support his ouer well first of all we're
going to go through the investigation
what's really interesting this is a
former principal here you're not going
to do cuz you're not even the
speaker any dumb ass yeah he's
he's a he's a free agent in his own
words M what a fire alarm is this is a
man that has gone out and yelled at
members and his behavior has been
Unbecoming this man is the most
experienced with fire alarms okay he was
a prin
oh that's actually a good point
that is a good point that man was a
principal he doesn't know what the
a fire alarm does I don't buy it yeah
dude he was trying to delay the vote dud
that's not a bad
point if it really was just an accident
when the capitol police came to
interview you why would you lawyer up
right away yeah why cuz smart smart yeah
Works in government man knows hello yeah
what the why would you what of
course you lyer up when cops
talk to you what do you mean what what
the always always always it's
literally the smartest thing you can do
okay even if you are innocent okay dude
that's awesome that he said that anyone
that lawyers up is clearly guilty that's
the best I love that not not Trump
though not Trump how many many like a
thousand lawyers yeah oh my gosh I made
a mistake here why would you let it go
on what do you everybody knows Let It Go
on you know how to get to they're making
it seem like this this like minor app
even stopped the process for any amount
of time when it literally didn't okay
like the funniest thing is the much
large the reason why this story got
buried even though we're we're rehashing
it because it's so funny is because the
much larger more important thing that he
was supposedly trying to quote unquote
delay happened immediately after so of
course that was the much larger more
important thing which was Voting in the
clean
resolution uh bill which they all did
including Jamal
Bowman right it's not even a benefit to
delay that process like why the
would he do
that yeah love them he knew this was all
Wonder everybody if you know this
individual everybody knows and if you've
been a principal you've had fire alarms
and you had children pull fire and they
and you know what happened to those kids
they were put to death as well
yeah um anyway so that's a fun little
wrinkle that's been happening oh yeah
George Santos my boy says it's
treason yes I can't believe how much
that piece of locked out like
everybody kind of forgot
about insane amounts of lies and and uh
because like so much has happened now in
Congress it it blows my mind that he's
just he's just carrying on like not like
nothing yeah it's it's
incredible oh no this is is the one that
I want American Congress is a
clown show I'm actually happy that
people are finally coming to terms with
that reality especially the House of
Representatives because like look at I
mean you got in the Senate you have Bob
Menendez okay in the House of
Representatives you have Matt Gates who
has an Ethics uh investigation conducted
on his uh improper dealings with a minor
sex trafficking and minors potentially
there was a active federal investigation
on it which they suspiciously dropped
which he literally asked for a pardon
from Donald Trump on uh before the
investigation was even concluded uh you
know it's just these guys are all insane
they're all out of control and they can
kind of get away with whatever the
they want because there's always a new
thing happening in the Carnival
you know but this
guy I mean he just he's such a
phony the man has no credentials anyway
here he is doing a sassy little uh
tutorial about fire alarms which I like
I enjoyed it Congressman George Santos
this here is a fire alarm that suit is
awesome if you lift this part here and
pull this down you trigger an alarm
don't do it stay good kids bro aren't
you the guy that stole money from like
an animal shelter and and like from
stole someone's dog yeah don't do don't
tell me about fire literally stole a dog
dude why is he not in jail I mean
honestly he stole someone's dog he just
took their a homeless vets
dog no he he he got it he denied it the
treatment what do you mean he stole he
didn't he didn't he take it to some
treatment center and then and then
didn't give it back or something
no I don't think so I apologize he's not
a dognapper he's just
yeah normal con man okay so moving on uh
that's one funny little tangent moving
on we've got uh Kev Kev kav Cav
a lot of people just hate to see a a
latinx man win you know right that's why
they're hating on George Santos and Bob
Mendez also he's a holocaust surviv or
his grandmother was a holocaust Survivor
yeah that's right uh Zach is pointing
out that he owns the same suit as George
Santos you look much better in it thank
you and just want to look at the watch
yeah if you want to oh okay it's hard to
tell from the he's got George Santos's
whole house on what wait you have two
watches on what's the other cuff oh it's
a bracelet oh it's a bracelet yeah but
uh yeah great uh Ralph Lauren suit
Macy's on
sale yeah you went boss mode he was
definitely giving car salesman more than
uh than you were also that's also the
Lego lose suit so he's bricked up brick
break up so let's see we are um the vote
was cast 216 to 210 the first time the
speaker's been removed ever yeah here's
the eight Republicans that voted with
the UK
now yeah we do have we do have a lot of
like weird procedural hurdles now like
European social democracies and none of
the amenities of a European social
democracy yeah like no adequate public
transit oh my god the guy on the top
right looks like fat asmin gold what the
I never had seen that before what's
happening there is that asthma gold
interesting so are this is the eight
Republicans that voted to
imp or remove Traders and so are people
people they gota be pissed at these guys
right uh the Republicans yeah yeah yeah
oh no for sure uh Fox News has been uh
bullying them and criticizing them a lot
um and and you know it makes sense they
are quite literally showing the American
population that at a time when like
they're supposed to be uh circling the
wagons preparing for uh you know
preparing for for this for this national
race that's about to happen in the
general election against like um against
Joe Brandon uh who is historically
unpopular they're having all this back
and forth that helps the Democratic
party a lot yeah because people
hate people hate process in America if
you want to if you want to get something
done it doesn't matter you could like
I'm not even kidding you could Institute
a nationalized Healthcare System
tomorrow if you got it done in like
under 76 hours obviously that would
never happen but the longer you hold out
the more back and forth and the more
deliberations happen in the legislative
side the more people get annoyed at it
the more time you have to like set up uh
you know lies about how you know
Obamacare is going to create death
panels and stuff like that which they
did at the time and uh Americans hate
that they they already hate Congress and
they hate when it's gridlocked uh they
hate this kind of back and forth so I'm
glad that the Republicans are doing it
now instead of the Democrat yeah they
look they just look like such
idiots it's awesome here's the minute he
got fired uh let's get the look on his
face on this
vote the yays are
216 the Nays are 210 the resolution is
adopted without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table the
office of speaker of The House of the
United States House of Representatives
is hereby declared vacant boom and then
the floor falls out under
Kevin the trap door is he in the room
yeah he's in the room yeah I want to see
his face oh they didn't they didn't cut
to him which did he vote
[Laughter]
for um the motion of
vacate uh the speaker's position was led
by Gates as we know and these other
Republicans now everyone's pissed at
them the reason you know I thought the
Democrats might cut a deal with him but
there's some really interesting stuff
that led up to it for
example the Sunday
morning before the vote he went on Fox
News and just
lied uh or faced the nation is that Fox
News I don't
know uh Face the Nation Face the Nation
it's not Fox News CBS yeah CBS and so
he's like no the Democrats want shut
down and then everyone's like dude
this guy most of in the Press probably
thought we would have shut down
yesterday too but no we did not were you
confident we wouldn't shut down I was
confident I could get something on the
floor to make sure the option that we
would not that our military well well I
wasn't sure it was going to pass you
want to know why cuz the Democrats tried
to do everything they can not to let it
pass they didat were the ones who voted
for this number pause for a second this
is the reason why
um this is the reason why he's just such
a bad politician and Nancy Pelosi would
never okay as much as I hate Nancy
Pelosi she's a great politician she's
very good at at her job which is
oftentimes doing bad
policy Kevin
McCarthy this is the speculation inside
of the democratic party at least Kevin
McCarthy did not realize that the
Democrats would just drop the Ukraine
funding immediately because they
recognize something that he doesn't
Ukraine funding is bipartisan Ukraine
funding is packaged under military
industrial complex Appropriations which
will always pass okay so of course they
don't give a about adding it on the
clean resolution like they'll
make a big stink about it they want to
put it through they want to push it
immediately but they're they could just
hold out and do it later as a separate
spending package because ultimately
that's always going to pass because red
States also have Ron locked Martin north
of Grumman and other facilities that
produce some of these weapons that want
this kind of uh spending to happen
right so yeah they all immediately voted
for the clean resolution they like okay
fine yeah no Ukraine spending all right
got it fine Fair let's go he thought
that they wouldn't do that he thought
that the Democratic party would hold out
and say no we are going to not pass a
clean resolution that we had formerly uh
negotiated on to begin with uh for the
next and and you know solidify a prision
for the next 45 days uh unless the 20
billion dollar Ukrainian uh uh funds
package was also tacked onto it he was
wrong they they collectively voted on it
of course they
did that was his major issue right he
thought that they wouldn't vote for it
that's why he's saying that right now
he's like oh the Democrats are holding
up process like no they weren't
idiot they all voted for it I mean she
does a good
job alive did you watch the floor
yesterday yes 90 Republicans voted
against it did you watch the floor
yesterday yes I did okay oh okay cool
then yeah you're right um so he went on
the night before the vote and tried to
blame the Democrats which I think pissed
everyone off and then the other thing he
did which was interesting is that he
called up the Democrats and specifically
said hey just so you know I'm not I'm
not willing to give you anything from
demat no talks no nothing vote for me
because it's the right thing to do oh
yeah I love this all over the floor
speaker what are the Democrats asking
you for as as you try to build support I
imagine from Democrats in this case I
imagine they're going to try to drive a
hard bargain you know what they haven't
asked for anything I'm not going to
provide anything and let's just be clear
okay uh when Nancy Pelosi was the
minority leader she would always come in
and she told Boehner and and Paul uh
that she didn't believe in them
utilizing this how they removed Boehner
that she would always vote it down not
based upon saving an individual but
based upon what's good for government
what's well that didn't work out for you
did it yeah oh that's crazy I can't
believe the Democrats showed backbone
for the first time ever it's
almost like it is literally uh and oid
nanu had a really good take on this like
Democrats exercising back phone and
doing like literal actual good politics
which is what the Republicans do all the
time and it's expected from them
is is so shocking true I didn't to the
Republican party that they're like it
might as well be
unconstitutional they're like what no
you're not supposed to do that you're
supposed to protect the institutions
right like you're supposed to to follow
process what are you doing you can't
unseat the speaker what that's never
happened before it's like dog you
literally didn't even offer concessions
to conservative Democrats okay that's
why they came out of that caucus and AEM
Jeff was like yeah we're not going to
save him what are you out of
your mind I'm no fan of Hakeem Jeff okay
this is Nancy Pelosi's guy all right he
is openly anti-progressive but he did
good politics there okay uh we do not
agree on policy we usually don't agree
on politics but he did good politics
Democrats did the right thing in the
situation and it was shocking for the
GOP they were like whate it's a
good thing to see man like I did not
expect it at all and it's it's so insane
because the
Psychopaths on the the article side of
liberal mainstream media at the New York
Times and at the Daily Beast and
all these conservative losers
are now cutting articles about how the
Republican part is imploding here is why
it's the Democratic party's fault for
not saving Kevin McCarthy and it's so
stupid because yeah Kevin McCarthy is
more moderate than Steve SC Poli or
whatever kind of Psychopathic
vampire they're going to put into that
position right certainly but it doesn't
matter because he never legislated in
that direction anyway he never offered
any concessions to the Democrats just
because he's supposedly more moderate
doesn't change the reality that it
doesn't matter if it's Steve
scales or Kevin McCarthy you're still
opening up an impeachment inquiry into
Joe Biden without any evidence
whatsoever you're still holding up
legislation like you're not you're not
doing a different job than the most
right-wing speaker uh would you're just
doing the same
job yeah um yeah dude the
expectation that the Democrats were
supposed to save the Republicans without
a single line item without a single
concession is so psychotic unless you
operate under the notion that the
Democratic party is supposed to be the
controlled opposition party who just
sits there and eats and the
defends this like theoretical supposedly
moderate Republican uh party it's so
dumb it's pretty incredible how smug he
is about like oh they're going to vote
to keep me don't you worry I'm not going
to offer them bye-bye dummy
institution as a whole and that's the
question has to be are we now in a
situation in our government that we just
provided keeping government open that
we're going to play politics with how
you become speaker that's the case then
I think we've got real problems yeah no
we got problems bro you know I mean
what the now you care about
procedure and dumbass loser bye
idiot like the saddest part about this
for the Democrats is that if Kevin
McCarthy went to more conservative House
of
Representatives uh Democrats in the
House of
Representatives he probably could have
secured enough V definely that like he
needed like eight guys you know what I
mean you don't have eight dudes
easily to defend you in the House of
Representatives on the on the Democratic
side you absolutely have those guys yeah
okay but he didn't because he was like
yeah it don't matter it don't matter
they they will vote to defend me because
they his play was like if I cut
a deal I'll look bad so I'm confident
I'm going to win without it I'm not
going to do that I'm not going to yeah
his original play was the rats won't
vote for the clean resolution because
he's just not a good politician that's
it he's from Bakersfield man yeah big
over overall to just have a dude from
Bakersville be the Speaker of the House
secondine of the president to our to our
friends in Bakersfield but I mean come
on no all
disrespect here is um this this video
cracked me up he was named the uh
temporary
speaker and here he is adjourning the
house and boy he was waiting for this
moment for that gabble man he was is
dreaming of this moment watch oh you
think the disantis height stuff is
bad really look up this look up this
man's uh mishaps on that front he's like
53 let's go does he have boots like
crazy boots and stuff no he stands
literally on a crate when he gives
interviews that's fair I mean he fo I
mean that's fair he wants to you know at
least he's a front about it yeah anyway
here he is chair declares the house and
recess subject to the call of the
chair chair I can't tell if he was
pissed or if he's just oh he's pissed
he's just excited that's Kevin
McCarthy's guy that's his boy oh it is
that's his boy he's like they did him
dirty I don't believe it I'm going slam
this hammer
down just like it's meant to be
done pissed man declares the
house to the call of the
chair chair declares a one of the
funniest things that they did did was
immediately in the interim like prot
temporary speaker went and like uh took
away uh uh stoyer and uh Nancy Pelosi's
like uh room in the
capital like they cuz they have the what
you speaker of the house like their
offices they immediately were like we're
reing you we're kicking you out bro ncy
Pelosi wasn't even there she didn't even
vote for or against Kevin
McCarthy she was at Diane
Feinstein's funeral right so like you
know that that's it just goes to show
it's all spite it's all Petty
they're like yeah you guys we'll
show you you no longer have a office
true I mean the I mean damn you expect
you don't expect these people to be S so
childish and such like Petty losers oh I
I 100% expect it but they are catty
little and and the best part we
need a reality show man the best part
about this is that like none of this
fixes the internal struggle the interp
party struggle in the GOP they still
have the same issues are they leaning
into the culture Warriors that want to
obstruct for the sake of obstruction
without uh any punishment whatsoever you
are a policy lless party at this point
your your goal is just death and
destruction and you constantly have to
push the boundaries you constantly have
to push the boundaries the Democrats
aren't giving you anything to fight
against so when you're the one leading
the charge on policy and your main goal
is to deregulate and and just like
remove Cil
Liberties people are going to
understandably get mad at that like roie
Wade so they are in this spiritual
struggle where they just have to figure
out which direction they go in like do
we become even more fascist or do we
dial it back do we re it in if we Reign
it in then you know we're no different
than the Democrats in general oh no not
Yang oh yeah here here's his we used to
love Yang never I on him
from the jump I loved him he was my
favorite uh friend of the show actually
or what well yeah he's a friend of the
show but here he is with a really
moronic take if you put politics uh
political gain ahead of countryes
Interest which is the Norman DC we are
lost shut the
up he's basically making exactly the
argument that uh ham is articulating
some people making earlier yeah because
it's it's just not fair it's like the
Republicans get to do whatever the
want and then the Republicans have to be
the Democrats have to be the adults it's
like n hey dog how about you shut the
up how about you win an election
one time okay suck my dick I don't want
to hear your analysis dude this
is look why why do we do this why do we
have all these
losers giving opinions on what to do
especially when they're like you're not
even a politician you've never done any
politics he's never even been elected
you're a two-time loser get the
hell out of here I don't want to hear
from your it's not good politics
because what's good politics is just you
know passively uh enabling the
Republicans to do whatever the they
want every goddamn time that's not
politics do not when your enemy is
making a mistake do not interrupt them
that's it right sunu he said that
yeah he was right the are you doing
here besides frankly this is a loss for
the country uh and Laura's list had
Ukraine aid number one imagine if you
were one of the US's partners
around the world or Ukraine itself his
title is former Democratic presidential
candidate that's accurate yeah that's
not that you're right yeah J former
Democratic US president former
Democratic presidential candidate Jen
yuger I mean how yeah how hard is it to
become a presidential candidate anyone
can do it I could be a paperwork let's
do that let's do that Dan I want to
become a presidential candidate so I can
have that title uh former Democratic
presidential candidate Ethan Klein
that's
sick saying dude let's do the paperwork
what part you want to run in the forward
party Andrew Yang could probably uh sign
you up no I want to do a Democrat I want
this title okay yeah I want this title
I'll uh I look into that I guess yeah
thank you hey guys uh where we're
fighting Russia here and then you see
that Aid to your military falls into
this abyss of American dysfunction I
mean our debt got downgraded just the
other day and you think if your uh
agency right now it's like it's the both
sides fence sitting hey come on
can't we all work together
guys that's why he's the man you know
he's not left or right's I'm not saying
one's better one's worse I'm just saying
can't we all work together I love this
because like it's just a less successful
Democratic party like I I it just
doesn't make any sense none of his I
mean he doesn't even have any like real
policy positions but like even The Vibes
he's putting out is just like like it's
just more democratic party like it
already exists out there you can just
vote for one of the two if that's your
goal right damn that's cold blooded we
need to pass a budget for hemming pants
That's cold blooded man yeah do you
think he brought the milk crate or
someone else did staffer staffer
probably carries it around yeah got in
the trunk wow I'm the mil crate guy some
cousin Greg looking 6'7 staffer
that just graduated from Yale and is
like related to Henry Kissinger
somehow has to Lug that crate around for
this guy everywhere they go here is
McCartney McCarthy right after he was
fired crying I'm so
sad my goals have not
changed my ability to fight is just in a
different form nope you need yeah more
like the the Ethereal form that it
doesn't
exist the spiritual realm he's so B made
it's it's funny because like one he's
not popular okay and the speakership
role is like you have to you have to be
a diligent whip like you have to be able
to whip your votes you have to be able
to control all manner of different
caucuses like Nancy Pelosi was so
good at that I as much as I
actually part of the reason why I hate
Nancy Pelosi is literally because she
was so good at that and did it
in uh with the most neoliberal positions
you could arrive at like pgo and things
of that nature and and Kevin McCarthy
cannot do that like he just was not
capable of doing that the speaker of the
house is a very important role probably
one of the most important roles in
Congress and it's one that actually
requires you to be charismatic uh to the
to your own caucus obviously and it
requires you to like actually do
work well third in line you know second
in line technically yeah but you're I I
made that same mistake cuz there a VPS
first in line oh I see I see yeah I did
the exact same thing yeah he's first um
but you know what's interesting is cuz
the the Republicans are talking about
getting Trump to be speaker which is
awesome dude that's just two uh two
accidents away from Trump being back
yeah so there's that part of the there's
that part of the craziness cuz like
obviously you know Joe brand is not
going to take much to
assassinate Joe Brandon let's be real
like he's already on his way out
um
so yeah someone's going to Spook him and
he's be like ah and then he he's going
to perish but
um but uh the the other re the real
reason why I want Trump to be speaker so
bad and you can't unfortunately there's
a rule that the Republicans implemented
I think that like you can't have a
felony indictment to be speaker of the
house we got to get rid of that yeah
yeah they uh they can um I looked into
that a little bit and it would basically
just be like a vote in their caucus
repeal that I like they go they go this
law is so important here here it is this
law is 26 and then they go no we don't
need that law right now I don't I wonder
if that was a Dennis hter rule like it
was 2002 I think I read that that was
initially wait oh so it is wait yeah so
it it was hter in by
then
speaker
Master of the House
yeah I think in the yeah 2007 is when he
got out yeah 99 to 2007 that might have
been a that might have actually
been a Dennis Haster rule because the
the I I forget where I read this but so
for those of you at home who do not know
who Dennis hasard is Dennis hasard is
the longest running still to this day
Speaker of the House of uh Speaker of
the House of Representatives uh he also
is one of the most prolific pedophiles I
was look I Congress I was going to say
that dude's a pedophile I'm sure of it
but you guys always get mad at me when I
say that no no no he is he's a pedopile
I was like that guy's a pedophile I'm
sure of it so the idea was that the
reason why they wanted Dennis hasard and
the reason why he was so uh the reason
why he was able to be the Speaker of the
House of uh representatives for so long
was because internally Republicans were
aware of his uh sexual deviancy criminal
acts and that they could use that to
control him and I I would I would
suspect that that rule probably was like
uh was a was like uh a rule that they
put in place because they were like well
if if you if you don't uh if you don't
do something we want you to do if you
don't put forward a bill that we want
you to P put forward for example you
know we'll just hit you with the
damn that's crazy I wonder if that's
probably the only time that they ever
did that use sexual blackmail to control
Congress people certainly that's never
yeah that's probably just the one off
then it's not happening right now well
one other one other uh spicy
drama inside baseball moment is um Matt
Gates apparently is very upset at
McCarthy for not standing uh against and
stopping an active ethics investigation
being conducted into Matt Gates which
was being conducted before there was a
federal investigation into Matt Gates uh
whose best friend is currently in jail
for sex trafficking miners he's in
prison for 11 years uh which Matt Gates
was also investigated for which was
suspiciously dropped by the federal
government so then the Ethics Committee
investigation restarted again he wanted
Kevin McCarthy to stop that
investigation uh and Kevin McCarthy was
like I can't stop it because it started
before I was even the speaker of the
house like it would be illegal for me to
stop an Ethics investigation what the
are you talking about so that was
one of the reasons why Matt Gates hates
Kevin McCarthy is what I've heard so is
that still happening why is gat yes it
is happening yeah yeah so here is um
here he is actually talking about a
Gates it's not a conservative every look
you all know mad
Gates you know it was personal it had
nothing to do about spending it had
nothing to do about everything he
accused somebody of he was doing it all
was about getting attention from you
shut up I mean we're getting email
fundraisers from him as he's doing it
that's pretty iconic if true join in
quickly oh I believe it yeah why would I
believe it yeah there's no way Kevin
McCarthy doesn't do that too I mean it's
yeah everybody Democrats do it too
they're like hey uh hey sorry uh sorry
to heat you up right now but do you hate
that all these babies died in the school
um you should give us money no this mass
shooting was super tragic we're the only
ones that can help prevent it yeah can
you please give us money that's true
uhhuh that's not governing that's not
becoming of a member of
Congress and regardless of what you
think I've seen the text it was all
about his ethics but that's all right so
so he's kind of doing something
interesting here he says I've seen the
texts is that he referring to some
evidence that's been in the well there
he say it's all about his ethics yeah he
says that inves I think he's signaling
yeah well and we'll see there's a a
couple other uh Republicans that are
pissed at Gates that have started to uh
spill the tea as it were so wait where
do you see that uh here
um it's in the reaction section from
establish Republicans are the blood a
bunch of these Charlie Kirk kind of
implied it on his stream wait let me
watch Benny boy I'm surprised these guys
are oh dude are you kidding me
this is such a major up Tim pools
is
supporting Tim's dummy who gives
a what Tim has to say Ben Shapiro
at least is like relatively sane and I
mean that doesn't mean much but like Ben
Shapiro understands that like that this
is bad that you have to have
like a a reasonable organized Republican
party that like at least somehow wins
elections because we're not at that
stage of fascism yet where you could
just like do whatever the you want
oh you still need to like win at
state legislator you still need to be
able to court pack in order to do that
you still have to hold a majority in the
house and also in the Senate you know
what I mean like for court appointments
you need to do that and so he wants a a
reasonable Republican party or at least
a Republican party that wins this is
something that the Republican party was
very good at the wedge issues that they
created uh were were created with the
express purpose of driving uh division
in the in the voting uh population so
that they could separate themselves from
the Democrats even though they're pretty
unified when it comes to tax cuts for
the wealthy uh some some moderate
regulation uh deregulation versus major
deregulation right like they're in the
margins there so they had to go into the
wedge issues talk about like uh gay
rights talk about trans rights talk
about abortion talk about gun control um
and and if if you are so lost in the
sauce in the culture War if you've
become a full-blown culture Warrior all
of a sudden Americans are going to start
going eh it's a little bit too much for
me right and and it this is bearing
itself out in the elections as well in
the midterms it's awesome that they're
covering it so much because that's how
people really find out about it too you
know but by the way in the top Fox News
been on Mt Gates love that yeah
yeah
because uh Republicans are
understandably very mad that this dude
is like playing the role of a spoiler
you're not supposed to obstruct uh the
Republicans you're supposed to obstruct
uh the Democrats right what does it mean
that two of the top comments on this
video are quotes of Thomas
Soul huh isn't that the guy who said
Obama compared Obama to Thomas soul to
uh Supreme Court of the United States
Justice Clarence Thomas's favorite
thinker who like red pilled him this was
the guy that um just ply think was
citing yes he's every racist favorite
black conservative yeah he's the
guy was he the slavery wasn't that bad
or like
many other among many other things yes
the slavery was was exaggerated welfare
destroyed black communities not the
criminal justice system so many so many
beautiful look how they love the top
comment Thomas also said that one of the
uh problems politicians have is that
they pay no price for being wrong we
need to kill him uh clearly that's what
he means I mean he's right though Thomas
saell I can't believe I'm saying this or
that commenter is right politicians
especially on the Republican Party do
not pay a price for doing the wrong
thing and um and this is a legitimate
problem especially in the Republican
party because the Republican base is is
so geared towards like ruining
Congressional process and I don't mean
this as like a January 6 joke I mean
literally like that's what they've been
doing since M McConnell has been uh uh
the the Senate leader they've just been
obstructing obstructing obstructing and
when they realize that in a extremely
polarized two-party system Sy that we
now have because uh there aren't any
like Regional differences there's no
geopolitics happening in American
Congress anymore like it did in like
even the 50s and 60s different states
had different interests right we don't
have that anymore uh you have two
different parties if you're a republican
uh in the North or in the South you have
the same interests if you're a democrat
in the North or the South you have the
same interests so Mitch McConnell tested
out this theory that if he obstructed
every single thing m that Barack Obama
was trying to push forward and uh he
would not get punished by the base and
he didn't and since then this is all
they've ever done they rarely ever pass
any bills they they actively undermine
uh you know the Democrat in positions of
power and their legislative agenda and
of course if that is your main goal and
your base is not punishing you for doing
that sometimes the obstructionist party
is going to be obstructed by another
person in their own ranks
let's see how Ben is apparently pissed
that the GOP had pretty much every
systemic Advantage going into 20124 they
had a deeply unpopular president of the
United States with approval ratings in
the high 30s low 40s a president of the
United States with approval ratings on
the economy in the 30s or 20s what if I
told you that the GOP had an economic
Edge on the issues that is their biggest
since 1991 true well what if I told you
that going into the election there was a
very solid shot that Joe Biden's
economic policies were going to Drive
America directly into a recession well
all of those things are true all of
those things are true somehow
Republicans have come up with a brand
new strategy this strategy is to join in
Idiocracy movie from the 2000s join in
the idiocracy show Al my balls this is
their actual strategy it's just to kick
themselves over and over in the balls
until they win true I cannot see any
other strategy here I I don't know why
it's happening it makes no sense to me
it is incredibly frustrating because I
would like to see Joe Biden not be
president of theed States I'd like to
see Democrats not make policy for the
United States I'd like Chuck Scher not
to be the Senate Majority Leader and yet
since Republican victory in 2016
Republicans have lost something like 11
governorships Republicans all right he's
so right he is reading the Republican
Party of the fil because pretty clearly
there because he's right Nikki Haley is
also right whenever she talks about this
there are still some like old school
sane conservatives I guess who just want
to be like let's get back to
deregulation like you guys are
up you guys are doing this like back and
forth nonsense and you're you're harming
our chances of like coming into
positions of power and actively
undermining the federal agencies from
within like Trump did you know what I
mean they have this major problem they
have a spiritual problem in the GOP
right now uh let's see Charlie Kirk is
is he threatening them sounds like maybe
so here what's happening right now this
is why the window needs to be filled
very quickly he's strange looking dude
he's so odd and I don't even mean that
as an insult I mean just I'm never seen
someone else that looks like him very
unique look this is the gayest
generation in American history right The
Establishment the uni Party The Bad
actors in DC they are out for
blood for the eight people that voted
against
McCarthy I've been just hearing whispers
about some of the Articles opposition
research you know rumors of things it's
about to get very very nasty sounds fun
uh so I like how he's on their side he's
like oh the the established Republicans
they're coming for him or whatever and
I've been hearing a lot of really bad
stuff about all my guys yeah so look out
like it isn't like oh I'm disgusted by
that it's like yo heads up heads up
buddy all of your crimes are about to
come out I don't think um this is a good
opportunity to remind everybody that
Charlie Kirk was anti-donald Trump
before Trump won the primaries just want
to point that out Charlie Kirk is uh a
person who cares about Charlie Kirk more
than anything else I mean he loves
Donald Trump now but uh I don't think he
has any allegiances to Matt Gates if
Matt Gates is doing stuff that's like
the bag up for the rest of the
Republican party in as public a fashion
as Matt Gates is the back up for
them so um this is the reason why I
think he's just saying like look Al
buddy and I think Donald Trump is also
very good at just like ripping uh his
own like loyal supporters over and over
again Kevin McCarthy included as a
matter of fact yeah so uh I don't think
he gives a about Matt gates at all
especially because he could probably say
Matt Gates is a Florida guy so he's
desantis's guy Matt Gates has actually
helped the santis do debates I mean this
guy this guy they're saying he's a
pedophile folks they're saying it for
little r the two I'm not saying it
they're saying it don't call him a
pedophile don't do it can't do it when
Matt Gates it has been proven yet when
Matt Gates came to me head in hand he
said please Mr President I love you
please pardon me I said what for you've
done no crime I thought what's going on
I've heard Matt Gates is a pedophile I
don't believe it though I'm not dude oh
God Trump should just hire me dog what
the I should just turn heel and
become a republican I would be so good
so here's Fox News getting super pissed
off about it all I'm furious first of
all we're without a speaker this is
historic something like this hasn't
happened in well over a 100 years now
what we got I thought it's never
happened yeah I thought so too I don't
know what you mean I I think this is the
first time that the speaker of the house
has been Ed yes yeah okay well she's
hedging her bet 100 years
knows when the Republicans are playing
out their infighting on National
Television in a historic way instead of
fighting Joe Biden's policies the one
time we are up in virtually every metric
as it relates to the Biden
Administration you got the Republicans
going out there and showing how
dysfunctional they are as Matt Gates is
engaging in fundraising and I got to
tell you something I am furious there's
no question that this is something that
they have been trying to do for almost
nine months at McCarthy's been speaker
and the truth is that they've done a lot
in Congress they've got a lot of bills
passed the fact that the Senate doesn't
want to take them they've done a lot in
terms of oversight and you know now
you've got the Democrats this is the
crazy thing Democrats who hate the Maga
Republicans are now joining with the
Maga Republicans to OU uh speaker
McCarthy this is like the devil is in
the middle of all of this chaos and
Donald Trump is right why are the
Republicans fighting with each other
like that it's awesome love love to see
it this one sounds juicy Mike Pence
Chief of Staff says what about Matt
Gates who's not a pedophile folks uh
don't the people who were masquerading
as fiscal conservatives really AR aren't
Jake I mean Matt gates to say he came
here as a fiscal Crusader it's more
likely he came here for the teenage
interns on
Capital isn't that epic this is
what I'm saying Mas off on him dude the
dude dude Mark short yo what a
King and that's Mike Pence's guy
the most milk toast in the world dud
what the yo they got daggers out
dude m is going to get that's
just a good ass line too that's funny
one more time awesome oh my God fre Nest
door free Nest door free Nest door till
it's spell backwards really aren't Jake
I mean Matt gates to say he came here as
a fisical crusader it's more likely he
came here for the teenage interns on
Capitol Hill to be honest
dudee that was so bro here's the
thing they've already been like throwing
out sussy on liners about how he like
apparently he takes uh Viagra and energy
drinks to go all night I saw something
like that they're just ripping
him they're Madison cing him right now
they're all it's all true by way you
can't go after you just can't you can't
disrupt process like this he's a
disgusting freak and it's all true you
know yeah so I love that Matt Gates
thought because he's like a Florida
Congress person you know pedophilia and
and uh getting a DUI would be a
prerequisite which it is if you're a
Florida Congress person it kind of is
you have to get a DUI um especially and
and now in in the National stage people
you know sometimes have an issue with
that turns out show us
so the really interesting uh twist and
all this is hold on a secret weapon is
brewing could it be could it be I want
this so bad is telling me at this hour
some House Republicans have been in
contact with and have started an effort
to draft former president Donald Trump
to
be they're so horny they wrote frer like
look some House Republicans are trying
to draft frer president Donald Trump
like they were so excited toam out real
quick they were slamming the
keyboard on that Chiron they were like
they nutted so true and I have been told
uh that uh president Trump might be open
to helping the Republican party at least
in the short term if
necessary if it's needed anyway yes so
good I love how he's saying his his
sources which like isn't they're like
dog yeah I mean sources are Donald Trump
it's so good please please
please make this happen please that'll
be so interesting CU clearly Trump
doesn't know anything about procedures
cuz everything in there is like super
super highle procedural
it's going to be such a amazing
show you can be president and not know a
single thing and you'll be
carried around Joel Brandon is like
barely a alive human and he's
like doing a phenomenal job right um but
you cannot be the speaker of the house
and not do all of the wheeling and
dealing all of the conniving politics
like it is the most political position
it is the most politics position you
need to know all the procedures you need
to like go through all of these like
different Loops like you have to
get your caucuses together Donald Trump
would kill himself in that
position be like this is the worst thing
I've ever had to do just not do it no
what she do she she went for a cord for
a cable but it's fine she didn't come
here baby oh God Trump posted this with
the with the gavel and the hat in the
chamber he's in baby and I mean like if
you ever seen that speaker of the house
the they're speaking like
another language it's so bureaucratic
it's so procedural he there's no shot
let's indict the God it
would be amazing it would be amazing I
love that oh it would be
amazing I want so bad let's get the
hammer in hand people I mean that's that
would tank his presidency I feel like
for sure he would look like such a
dumbass no I think that he I mean it
would be
horrible uh he would just do such a bad
job he would just hate it it would be
awesome um it it'd be horrible for the
country but like I mean what isn't what
is good for the country at this point
you know what I mean I'm just I'm just
in it for the
fun yeah one more time well I think
it'll it's appropriate give them a few
days to get away come back on Tuesday
have a form allow people to present
their issues forward but I think that
what's what's concerning is we really
are $33 trillion in debt we do have a
border crisis there's a lot of really
really aren't Jake I mean Matt Gates it
to say he came here as a fiscal Crusader
it's more likely he came here for the
teenage interns on Capal Hill to be
honest's voted for continuing with the
best
line that's not that's deliberate
they're coming they're coming for him
what a guy well that's about it I don't
know if there's anything else wait if
you're liking the Matt Gates thing you
got to this one last one you got to see
this clip oh I love the Matt Gates thing
so yeah yeah they're they're
he's not the only one they The Masks are
coming off pretty quick okay here we go
here we go
dude one house 400 faces dude 436 faces
you know you got to think about this guy
um this is a guy that didn't have that
the media didn't give a time of day to
after he was accused to sleeping with an
underage girl oh they all remember this
now of course all of a sudden they
worked shoulder toh shoulder they didn't
they didn't seem to care but now they're
just they really they're all so
concerned
about mull is especially just like a I
hate him so much Jesus Christ
republican from Oklahoma I mean he's a
senator too like yeah no the other guy
was like a former Chief of Staff to Mike
Pence but now we have like this real
we'll get more quotes like this
flying around I'm so glad that they're
interested in uh you know uh taking
people responsible for sleeping with
underage girls refreshing maybe Matt
Gates is like uh this is his like exit
strategy to be like oh yeah they came
after me and said I was a pedophile not
because I uh did sex trafficking in
minors but because I you know disrupted
Congressional process I don't know I
mean what's the go there Matt what's
going on there the agenda
yeah I've never felt more confident in
my position early on on like there was a
there was a back and forth going on with
forc to vote I don't know if you
remember this uh back in the day when
Nancy Pelosi was supposed to be voted in
for speaker and there was also a slim
majority and in the Democratic party it
was was wider majority than the one that
the Republicans have but still there
were some
people some at the time considered
themselves to be uh leftists others uh
are are no longer uh leftists that we
saying no do do this exact same thing
that Matt Gates is doing to force a um
to force to the floor a Medicare for all
vote mhm cuz because um they had it in
the house they had the majority in the
house they had the majority in the
Senate okay and it was I was very
critical of it I thought that it was a
silly thing to do because it would only
make uh it would only draw animosity to
progressives and Medicare for all in
general and it would ultimately be
catastrophic um with with no tangible uh
uh positives for the Progressive
Movement or Medicare for all cuz it was
very unlikely to pass it it was yeah it
was not going to pass like of course it
wasn't going to pass cuz Democrats don't
want Medicare for all Democratic
politicians don't want Medicare for all
and and at the time everybody yelled at
me but it seems like hey look at that do
you think Matt Gates is looking too good
right now looking too
hot well he also does have the sex
crimes going for him well yeah which
makes it a lot
easier to kind of even if he didn't have
it he would look bad
is good it's a good angle yeah one and
the conference came and defended him
because we had all seen the videos he
was showing on the house floor that all
of us had walked away of the girls that
he had slept with he' brag about how he
would crush medicine and and and Chase
it with with energy drink so he could go
all night this is obviously before you
got married and so that accusation came
out no one defended him and then no one
on the media would give him a time of
the day all of sudden he found Fame
because opposed the Speaker of the House
back in November and he's always stayed
there and he's not he was never going to
leave until he got this last moment of
Fame by saying by by going after a
motion to
vacate is he regretting this you think
Gates is like I probably up now
that everyone's calling him a ped I mean
how did he not see it like how did he
not see that this was going to happen to
him he was clout hungry he got clout
blinded clout Sheet's funny dude could
it know that he is uh probably on
all the ethics investigations and so by
doing this he can be like oh they're
just trying to uh theep is trying to
bury me because I stood up to Kevin
McCarthy the problem is like I don't
think there's a lot of appetite not that
good of a strategy the base won't punish
you for being obstructionist but like
that still doesn't change the reality
that like you are hurting the the
overall uh way that the the people view
the Republican party if all your call
colleagues are doing media appearances
calling you a
pedophile yeah that's not going to be
good for the image for like before it
could be like oh it's a partisan attack
from the Democrats but now every the
best part of this is like the battle
lines are being drawn right and
everyone's like kind of on Matt
gates for understandable reasons and
it's like there's so much wonderful
opposition research opportunities here
for like every single Republican to just
like point the finger at everyone that
now has Associated themselves at any
point with the radioactive brand of Matt
Gates that you can just like they don't
I don't even think they foresee the the
the backlash that they themselves will
receive from this like I mentioned this
hurts Ronda santis Matt Gates Florida
Congress person Matt Gates is an Ali to
Ronda santis this is going to literally
rip uh Ronda santis further in my
opinion right so like Trump if I'm Trump
I'm using this against little Ronda like
little poor little Ronda taking enough
I'm saying the Republicans need me to
unite the party and uh no other
Republican can do that on the debate
stage I'm the only one to do it and uh
you know little Ronda loves Matt Gates
just like Matt Gates loves uh kids I
will
say oh come on don't say he's a
pedophile Hanan we don't know that he's
a pedophile allegedly we don't know m is
a pedophile come on um he's also a very
strange looking guy very strange yeah he
looks like like a villain he just has
like villainous Vibes always I don't
know what it is that's what love said
this morning when I had him pulled up on
my screen he was like he looks like a
bad guy he does so mean mat Gates does
have the opportunity the funniest thing
though I'm just saying like when he's
going out don't go out like a coward
dude go out like a hero make with that
information do with that information
what you will
knives are out they're coming to gut you
do the damn thing fight back
don't back down that look at this
that's he's like what the
how villainous can you look he's
got like evil eyebrows Jesus he looks
like that bad guy from Roger Rabbit or
something all right anything else no I'm
I'm good
well good times fun times good times
exciting times
and if Trump becomes speaker please I
just at least try like let's make a an
honest effort to make that happen I am
fully in support of Donald Trump
becoming the speaker and then acting
like the speaker uh position means that
he can't be tried anymore cuz like
that's what's going to Happ mising I'm
the Speaker of the House you can't try
me for real though how what's the
likelihood you think that Trump might
become speaker no I I I don't think so I
think it's like way more likely for it
to be Jim Jordan uh or maybe Steve skiz
even though he's like dying right now
well that's perfect I think Steve skiz
has like blood cancer or something right
oh I hadn't heard about that he has like
some some
different David Duke
scist yeah David Duke without the
baggage without the baggage I'm sorry
David Duke without the baggage The Good
the good David Duke
yeah what's David Duke's baggage hat
being a racist just people knowing that
he's a Clansman I think is his baggage
like if if people don't know that you're
a Clansman but you have like Clansman
politics then they can't say that for
you God he's such a weird looking dude
look at this
man I say have fun with it you don't
have to be in Congress or a uh sitting
politician to be
representative all right well thank you
everybody tomorrow we're having our
house
uh
update Trump considering visiting
Capital next week go do it let's get him
in there waste no
time um thank you everyone we'll be here
tomorrow for our big membership Drive
Extravaganza starting at 11 much better
than this episode yeah it's possible
it's more than likely yeah more than
likely very very likely we have a really
fun episode planned tomorrow so there's
pretty much no shot that it won't be
better than this um
thank you guys for Watching God Save the
Queen or
the all right that's
that
[Music]